buddy welcome back to the Samsung stage
on the final day of e3 I'm your host cam
Robinson I'm joined by two lovely gentle
and we have Ryu Michael how you doing
guys hey welcome to the stage let's go
for the handshake thank you why not it's
it's the right thing they do felt right
okay so guys you are going to show off
rise of incarnate today now if you're at
home right now our viewers they haven't
heard of Reisman Carnot's what is it
give us give us a Luna okay I guess
we'll ask the executive producer review
about this so sure what do you think
suzanne molinaro Mogae Miska i start a
new crew
brand new IP grand new system la terre
see it ivan gave this the monomer
rhizobian connects this is akansha SEMA
is completely play there it was
gosh this is me am I getting all got me
so this is a brand new title that we're
showing off at e3 it's a brand new IP as
well called rise over carnage
it's a free-to-play it's going to be on
Steam so with the basics match format is
it two one two and it's got elements of
both fighting and shooting kind of mixed
into this hybrid action as four players
as well four players yes cool so it's
two on two 3d fighting game rolling
around like that's kind of idea right
fantastic well actually got some as you
guys brought some footage with us yeah
so let's load up on screen and you guys
can maybe talk over yeah and let us know
what's going on give us a bit more
detail when I want to know about with
the action or with a combat in fact I
think we're starting with us a trailer
okay so it's just like this so tell us
the setting like where does this fight
take place what's going on in the world
so what person is exploding against
buildings this is actually the
announcement trail that we showed up
last month okay so this is taking place
in New York this is one particular stage
that the players will see first so as
you can see we have these people caught
in Carnot's and there are these humans
for some reason one day a special power
is kind of awoken in them and so the
incarnate they're able to call out this
deity to fight alongside of them either
a god or demon it depends on the
character some people call them some of
them and they'll fight alongside them
and some people actually transforming
this a hater in distress for yeah and so
they're actually set in real world
locations this being New York obviously
in the Alpha we actually had a alpha
test that we allowed
to play last month and New York was the
first stage so as you can see you've got
two on two he actually just summoned the
character there so he's fighting
alongside him yep
it's called Aries and he's actually the
deity will mirror what you're doing so
if you shoot he shoots with you if you
fight he fights with you you can send
them off for an attack and then you can
combo on him so each of these unique
abilities each character possesses
something the one you saw Grim Reaper at
the end of the trailer he's really cool
a tricky care - he'll call forth these
zombies and you can send them to attack
your enemy maybe they'll kind of hold
them while your gallant on them you can
shoot the zombies and make them bigger
so he has a lot of cool tricky
techniques but the the action itself is
a two-on-two yes and the controls are
very simple so you know a lot of
fighting games people are maybe kind of
skittish at first because they think
they have to be able to pull off these
very complex commands but this isn't the
case so you have very simple controls
and they're standardized so you don't
learn one character you can you can I
usually pick up another one and just
really get started right so where the
depth of gameplay actually comes about
is a you and your partner how you fight
together so you might want to kind of
team up on your opponent and double-team
them so can you do things like I don't
know a look one person knocked up in the
air and other person juggles them with
guns or anything
yeah all right cool so with some of the
melee attacks for example if you've been
put forward in melee do this a cool
combo that most of them end in a
launcher and if your partner is it close
by and they're watching you'll see this
prompt on screen where they can either
input a shoot button to do a shooting
attack to finish the combo or close by
they can do a melee and they'll jump up
an air grab the opponent's slamming them
into the ground
are those kind of cool things for the
spectacular damage so it's all about how
you work together with your your partner
to this that character seem to be like a
giant walking robot right so the trailer
they're showing right now this is what
the new one we had for e3 okay so we
initially had four characters at the
alpha build and in this character you'll
see two which are quite different from
the other four brynhilda she's riding
the motorcycle very quick movement yep
and then there's the Odin who's riding
the tank yeah so he's kind of a little
bit slower but you
these missile attacks and in such and so
you saw the laser right where we just
destroyed the ark teaching home yeah
which actually happens in game there's a
serious destruction and that laser is an
actual attack that he possesses so you
can see there's a lot of variety in the
characters you can choose the one that
suits your playstyle and so for a team
right we're going to want to make a very
compatible team so maybe helping Odin so
he can attack from behind with a massive
shooting attacks
I'll pick maybe the blonde haired guy
Ventress off leaves because he's very
good at the Coulson attack so I'll be on
the frontline keeping them at bay while
he pounds them from the career so
there's this different not only who you
choose but how that works with the
character your partner's chosen as well
that's cool so it's kind of the essence
it's one two she said it's a free to
play game commence Christine um so how
many characters are kind of available
you know without paying anything when
it's free and how did you go about
unlocking though if you want to choose
other characters well currently you know
we've had four playable and then the two
characters were showing now we're still
in alpha we have a beta coming up soon
we have an announced to date yet so
these are only the six that we've been
out so far but you know we'll be
updating the game it's online so
updating with new content be that stages
new customization items and such and
will gradually be releasing new
characters as well but what we can talk
about this point are those things okay
um and how much you envisage it like it
costing for a new character Jeff you
thought about costing yeah if you have
any ideas well it's always a tricky one
is inspiring you're right singles yeah I
guess monetization is one thing that a
lot of people are worried about with the
free-to-play game since this is a new IP
and it's a new play style for the West
it's two-on-two concept we wanted them
to be able to play the game as much as
possible so there's no kind of stamina
system or or you know pay to play kind
of stuff so people are going to be
playing the game as much as they want
where we monetize is the actual
customization of the character so
alright so the look of them so you have
access to all the characters all the
time I don't like the characters is
something we're still discussing
internally
like it's not it's not going to be
necessarily as simple as you know you
pay money for this character where's the
other ones free or it could be to be
paid for it could be that you unlock
through gameplay okay that's something
we haven't really worked out yet
yeah we'll have some more details on
that later on it sounds good I mean I
guess
how does it work for who's obviously
fighting games balance is super
important right right and I guess it
must become slightly more complicated
co-op element right because some payers
are gonna be way more powerful than
others so how do you RG balance
preparing I say absolutely no this is
especially for Purdue so I think cuz
he's been working on the Gundam versus
series in Japan and uh Kellan of Anna's
gonna come yes my together sit there but
so go take another pass on your local oh
no Larry Tyson got to give me a tonight
I know it's touching to say let's get a
more forgiving of Anita EDA denote a
scientist named coastal system my life
with Jim large birthday from cache
system top ten is good mom so no balance
no chose Eddard oka Otto ah Kimia Zinio
de Sena true character Costa guy
carrados Cosmo hey I see Danny parsley
okay
Simo kuku bootcamp they I didn't I said
Oh señor gotaro Ducati co-occur oh no
naka no game no evidence no necesito
Brando no comedy are depe
no sir no vide art 0.0 naru karate name
windows phone I am NOT a nap at that so
you can fire Plato don don don don
I gotta come on a day another sighting
about us today it is Roberta a user name
is Antonia X I not video motor driver so
one thing that's kind of a staple of
these two on two games but the Western
audience is it very familiar with this
genre yet so you'll see these various
characters right like the female
character Lilith there's this a team
light pole that you share so for our
team we have our own characters life
gauge per se and then we have a team
life gauge and is a team life gauge just
the two characters ladies at your
particular tune so the way it works is
if Lilith if I'm playing us her and I I
get I die because I run out of my
characters health I can still respond as
long as we still have some team life
pool right and so you can do that as
many times as long as you have
that team lightpole still available
about you and the cost of the characters
is different so she's very quick not
very powerful attacks but very quick and
agile and so you're going to be moving
around and shooting while trying to grab
your opponent for powerful tap but since
she's not as strong for cost is very low
and then the other case a costuming cost
for like a respawn yeah from that team
light pole gotcha and then when you have
areas the guy who was summoning the
guide alongside him he's got a lot of
life his attacks are powerful so the
cost of it is higher so right so when
you died with him it takes a lot more of
your team light bulb so what do was just
saying was long way we balanced it is by
how much the cost of the characters is
set at so obviously like a fighting game
he was saying that you know their
attacks they're their life how much
movement in such range they have all of
that stuff is balanced but on top of
that we kind of balance it with the cost
as well so we take these characters and
as you were saying it depends on the
pairing as well we pair all these
different characters to make sure that
there's no like broken team or something
like that yeah
and so that's what one of the main
staples is as he was saying and also
it's an online game so if something
occurs that we weren't foreseeing we can
address that as well you can update it
and address balance issues like that I
mean I guess I'm sure as you add more
characters you're gonna have to
constantly rebalance but part it I think
it's like just part of nature about
producing online games today it says
right which is but it's great right
mimis yeah constantly give us the you
know the best experience you're trying
to get which is say it's pretty sweet
and now if you're watching us at home
actually and now you've got some
questions rather Michael array then the
best thing to do be to tweet at me and
then it's at cam Fras Rob I got Twitter
open right here in front of me and I
will throw the questions to these guys
so that's at sea am and facts go up on
screen there it is that cam 4s Rob I
will do my best
pass him along so who's tell me about
this character so you said you've shown
off is it six in total so far so right
you're saying on meta staff please uh so
we refer to them by their deity named
the deities that they summon or
transform into or taken from mythology
from around the world so you know
mephistopheles though
Ares you have all these different
well-known deities so he is your kind of
average guy where as far as Costco's not
too low not too high as such his
abilities are pretty much you know the
standard he's almost kind of like a main
character in the game as well so as you
see he has the all of them have shooting
attacks and melee attacks right and
depending on the character for example
Ares is a stronger shooting attacks
where some characters a better at melee
he's kind of balance between both he can
do both pretty girl and as you see he'll
transform into the deity mephistopheles
so he turns into this red and black
demon as you also saw in the trailer it
looks pretty cool right
and so his melee attacks I hold for the
person up in the air and he'll continue
to do multiple attacks and then slam
them into the ground his shooting
attacks are also enhanced when he's in
his transform state but it's a limited
amount of time that he can transform and
then you have to wait for the cooldown
so until he can use the ability again
but that also depends on the character
for example Lilith she can transform at
any time as long as she's close to the
opponent and kind of a throw mechanic
where she'll grab them kiss the kind of
a kiss of death per se and then
transform into her alternate incarnate
and she doesn't have a time gauge or
anything she can do that as often as
you're able to grab your opponent so
it's really unique depending on the
character well I am I've just got one
question from Twitter and that is
actually what platforms or platforms
will rise of Carnot's be coming out on
so you mentioned steam and PCs there any
plan to bring it to any consoles or
anything like that by the Sun at all II
must impede on aikidoka no consult
autocopter so his name Master Kenobi
Nagato get a 90cm oh yeah pari kook
agree to play no more dare to go Toto an
ogre - Annie Kanu gave me a token IPO
here okay yeah no asan demerit I system
when I try to you know commit a Amara
similar pretty to play there Bardot I do
that shaky but total identity that
consignee I try not to keynote Oh
Machado nice engine empty timing Gras no
console intent concreted over martin de
la maza herrera seaman they say cause
austere Matsumoto
nah tink erotic stay not Halle I'm
American Idol
so basically this is a this one - is
kind of a well-known genre in Japan but
not so much in the West and this paired
with this all-new IP is something
totally new to the this audience right
so we wanted to have as many people as
possible and give it a try because we
pretty confident they'll like what they
see but to do that that's why we chose
steam first because the timing when the
concept came up was right around the
time when ps3 and 360 were the mark was
pretty right but we weren't seeing the
next-gen consoles yet so to reach you
know a lot of gamers out there we wanted
to go to steam and then free-to-play so
first that's that's our objective yeah
and we're going to be we have a lot of
exciting things to look forward to and
hopefully when we have a lot of people
excited and playing the game and we have
a good fan base out there then if
they're asking for something else it
might be possible that's all I'm only so
you can see how it goes to steam and
then see if you can bring in this where
after it's wonderful guys right thank
you so much for coming on stage and
showing a Verizon card it's been a
pleasure and damn yeah make sure you
enjoy the rest of your III now if you're
watching at home don't go anywhere we're
going to cut away for just a few minutes
but then we're going to be back on stage
and Lisa Foyle's who's been all over e3
wandering around for gains bought
chattington loads of interesting people
she's coming up on the stage having a
chat with me so we're back in just a few
minutes